Guten Tag. Ich heiße Dr. Korkmaz. Ich bin der Dienstabender auf dieser Station. Ich würde mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Gerne.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen, möchte ich ganz schnell Ihre personische Daten aufnehmen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Peter Hund.
Peter Hund.
Könnten Sie Ihre Vornahme langsam rüfteln?
E wie Portugal, E wie Estland, T wie Türkei, E wie Estland, R wie Grisad.
Peter. Mein Name ist Hund.
Herr Hund, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin genau 51 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie geboren?
24. Januar 1972.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,70 m groß und wiege circa 73 kg.
Herr Hund, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Warum ich Sie heute aufsuche?
Ich habe seit ungefähr 5-6 Tagen Oberbauchschmerzen, die nicht aufhören, sondern immer wieder auftreten und mir Sorgen bereiten.
5-4 Tage?
Die haben sich meistens plötzlich oder langsam angefangen?
Langsam begonnen, aber mit einer Beweile habe ich auch Übelkeit erbrechen und das macht mir wirklich Sorgen.
Sie haben auch seit 5 Tagen noch sehr?
Seit gestern.
Haben Sie schon erbrochen?
Ich habe auch schon erbrochen, ja.
Wie sieht Ihre Erbrechen aus?
Also gar nicht. Geld, Grün.
Geld, Grün.
Wie viele Mal erbrochen Sie?
Einmal. Gestern Abend.
Momentan haben Sie aktuell diese Schmerzen?
Ein bisschen weniger. Ich habe Schmerzabletten genommen.
Ich hatte noch zu Hause etwas, aber es drückt noch sehr stark.
Ich habe Schmerzen.
Könnten Sie bis Ende unserer Gespräche aushalten oder soll ich Ihre Schmerzmittel geben?
Ich versuche es aushalten.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Könnten Sie mir sagen, wo genau die Schmerzen am stärksten sind?
Sie sind genau im Oberbauchbereich, genau hier.
Auf der rechten Seite, aber auch links, das ist ein bisschen variierend.
Okay, stellen die Schmerzen irgendwohin aus?
Ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, als wäre es auch im Rücken.
Am Anfang habe ich mir gedacht, dass mein Rücken ist,
aber jetzt bin ich mir sicher, dass mein Bauch ist.
Es wird immer mehr.
Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzmittel genau beschreiben,
stechend oder dumpf?
Ich würde sagen, beides eher. Manchmal dumpf.
Manchmal habe ich aktuelle, dumpfe Schmerzen,
aber manchmal ist das auch wirklich wie,
als wenn man mit einem Messer reinsticht.
Stechen, okay.
Die Schmerzen immer da oder wählen für mich?
Nein, die sind immer da, dumpf, dumpfe Schmerzen,
die mal mehr werden, mal weniger werden,
aber es ist nicht wählen für mich.
Würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala einordnen?
Null, kein Schmerz und treibbare Schmerzen.
Jetzt oder wenn ich starke Schmerzen habe, was meinen Sie?
Wenn am stärksten ist.
Also dann würde ich schon 9 sagen.
9, okay.
Würde ich schon 9 sagen.
Jetzt aktuell habe ich vielleicht so 4,
um den 3, 4, 5.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie ein Schmerzmittel
eingenommen haben.
Richtig.
Welche Medikamente wissen Sie, die Namen der Medikamente?
Ich hatte noch Tropfen gehabt.
Neuvalginen Tropfen gehabt, wie habe ich genommen?
Ich hatte die letzten Jahre vom Hausarzt bekommen
wegen Schulterschmerzen.
Okay, und es war ein bisschen hip-like.
Ja, das hilft schon so ein bisschen.
Es glendet die Schmerzen, aber ich muss dann wiedernehmen.
Und die letzten 2 Tage muss ich immer mehr von den Tropfen nehmen.
Okay, früher haben Sie ähnliche Bescheven?
Hatten Sie früher ähnliche Bescheven?
Einen noch nie, das ist das erste Mal jetzt.
Okay.
Würden Sie Fibrik?
Wie bitte?
Ob ich Fieber habe?
Ja.
Nee, natürlich nicht.
Haben Sie Stolfrost, Schweißausbrut,
oder Nachschweiß?
Nein, nein, aber ich fühle mich sehr, sehr schwach.
Sie haben Müdigkeit.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Also leider gar nicht momentan.
Ich habe jetzt seit 2, der ist schon fast 3 Tagen kaum.
Also ich habe nicht das lange nach Essen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Also ich war jetzt auch die letzten Tage nicht auf Toilette.
Aber ich habe auch keine Probleme normalerweise.
Läste haben Sie gestern?
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Ich habe schon 3 Tage nicht zu Hause.
Vor 3 Tagen?
Ja, ich habe aber noch nicht zu Essen.
Okay.
Normalerweise hatten Sie Verstopfen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlösen?
Klären Sie über Herzgrasen oder Atmung?
Nein.
Ja? Okay.
Brauchen Sie, oder wie brauchen, wie viele Kisten brauchen Sie umschlafen?
Eins.
Eins. Okay.
Wieso haben Sie das gefragt?
Diese generelle, ich beurteile Ihre allgemeine Zustands,
auch Ihre aktuelle Wörter.
Wie viele?
Wenn Sie eine Herzprobleme haben,
brauchen manchmal viele Kisten umschlafen.
Das ist okay.
Deswegen frage ich.
Okay.
Herr Hocht.
Leiden Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen,
wie z.B. Leckerkrankheit oder Bluthochdrug?
Nein, ich habe nur ab und zu,
habe ich ein Gistanfall, deswegen nehme ich ein Medikament für die Harnsäure ein.
Seit wann haben Sie gix?
Schon seit 10 Jahren.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Ich nehme Alloporinol ein, einmal am Tag.
Okay.
Wann die letzte gix-anfall?
Das war tatsächlich schon lange her, also mehr als fünf Jahre jetzt.
Seiddem ich das Alloporinol nehme, ist weniger geworden.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und haben Sie noch etwas chronische Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Okay, sehr gut.
Also ich habe ab und zu Schulterschmerzen,
habe ich Ihnen gerade gesagt,
ein bisschen verschleißt, es wurde MRT gemacht,
aber dann muss ich auch Schmerz-Munikamente nehmen
und Physiotherapie, aber das ist auch schon besser geworden.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und nehmen Sie bei Bedarf Schmerz-Munikte.
Genau, Novagin zum Beispiel.
Welche Schmerz-Munikte nehmen Sie ein?
Novagin.
Okay, okay, entschuldigung.
Immer Novagin, okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft auf der Corona-Geräusche?
Corona-Hintung bin ich geimpft, ja, bin ich viermal geimpft.
Sehr gut.
Und haben Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, lange her, also mein Blinder muss entfernt worden,
da war ich noch Kind.
Okay, in der Kindheit.
In der Kindheit, ganz genau, ja.
Gab es damals eine Konflikation?
Nein.
Okay.
Herr Hund, leiden, ist Ihnen irgendwelche Allergie
oder Vorerkrankungen bekannt?
Vorerkrankungen haben wir gerade gesagt.
Entschuldigung, Unverzweglichkeit, ich habe falsch gesagt.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Nicht das höchste.
Okay.
Herr Hund, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Sie nicht immer?
Nicht raucher.
Ich bin nicht raucher.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ganz selten, also ich vertrag Alkohol nicht so gut.
Wenn dann nur bei Feiern, bei Geburtstagern,
dann lassen Sie es sehr selten.
Okay, gelegenlich.
Nehmen Sie nächste Frage nicht persönlich,
das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Erfahrungen mit Drogen?
Ja, nicht möglich, also ich nehme keine Drogen ein.
Okay, wir haben fast fertig,
aber ich möchte ein paar über Ihre Familienstand
und Familie geschickt ein paar Fragen stellen.
Wie ist Ihre Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Okay, was machen Sie bürglich?
Ich bin Lehrer.
Lehrer?
Okay, haben Sie Stress bei Arbeit oder Ihre Privatlevel?
Nein, ich bin wirklich verheiratet.
Ansonsten in der Schule, die übliche Stress mit den Kindern
und den Schülern, also eigentlich nichts Relevantes,
muss man sagen.
Okay, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Mein Vater ist gestorben, meine Mutter lebt noch.
Darf ich fragen, woran Ihr Vater gestorben ist?
Mein Vater hatte einen Magenkrebs.
Magenkrebs, okay.
Und wie alt war er, wenn er Krebs hat?
Er hat es recht früh erkannt, in den 40er-Jahren,
also ungefähr 40 war,
und dann ist er auch zeitnah verstorben,
leider, also innerhalb von vier, fünf Jahren ist er verstorben.
Okay, es tut mir sehr leid.
Hat Ihrer Mutter irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Ich weiß, dass sie einen Diabetes hat und ein Blutdruckdruck hat.
Okay.
Wissen Sie, welcher Typ ihr Diabetes hat?
Nein, weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, zu Kind.
Okay.
Was glauben Sie denn, was ich haben könnte?
Also diese Bauchschmerzen, diese Müdigkeit,
ich habe auch ein bisschen gemerkt,
dass ich jetzt geldliche Augen habe.
Ist das schlimm?
Es ist so früh zu sagen,
oder zu diagnostieren,
ich muss ein paar
operative Verfahren machen,
operative Test, zum Beispiel Bluttest
oder ja, Untersuchung, ja,
und dann je nach Ergebnisse sprechen wir wieder.
Aber machen Sie keine Suche,
wir haben eine große Erfahrung in dieser Krankenhaus.
Wir machen alle geeignete Tests für Sie.
Meinen Sie denn, es könnte was Schlimmes sein, was scharfe?
Nein, denken Sie bitte nicht am schlimmsten Fall.
Wir können Schritt-de-Schritt untersuchen,
durchführen und sprechen wie wir da.
Ich mache mir wirklich Sorgen,
ich bin noch jung, eigentlich möchte ich noch leben.
Ja, ich verstehe sehr gut.
Und gibt es viele Ursache für unsere Beschwerden.
Was kann das denn sein, was glauben Sie denn?
Das könnte sein eine Gallenblase-Probleme
oder Magenprobleme,
oder Bauchschilddrüseprobleme.
Bauchspeicheldrüse?
Bauchspeicheldrüseprobleme, ja.
Das wäre gefährlich, wenn es Bauchspeicheldrüse ist.
Manchmal könnte es sein, aber ich denke,
Sie haben nicht gefährliche Zeichen.
Meinen Sie?
Ja, aber ich mache alle...
Ich habe Gewicht verloren.
Ich mache mich schon Sorgen.
Ich habe vergessen, dass Fragen,
welche Zeitraum und wie viele abgenommen?
Ich habe jetzt in einer Woche 5 kg Gewicht verloren,
noch mehr Sorgen.
In einer Woche?
Aber Sie haben seit einer Woche keine Arbeit, oder?
Seit 3-4 Tagen, ich habe die Beschwerden seit 4-5 Tagen.
Im Anschluss habe ich Gewichtsverlust,
aber ich habe schon Feuer gehabt.
Die Schmerzen sind später aufgetreten.
Und diese Müdigkeit,
die ich bin so müde, ich könnte immer schlafen.
Okay.
Ihre Frau,
haben Sie bemerkt, dass Sie blässt?
Nein, ich habe keine Blässe,
aber ich habe eine leichte Geldverfärbung,
die Augen bemerkt.
Das hat auch meine Frau bemerkt.
Bei Augen, okay.
Das ist wichtige Information.
Ist das jetzt gefährlich oder nicht gefährlich?
Ich bin ein bisschen beunruhigt.
Ja, es könnte sein eine Leberprobleme
oder Kalanblaseprobleme, ja, vielleicht.
Ich fühle eine Sonografie führen.
Die Sonografie ist ultraschall, oder?
Ultraschall, ja, ultraschall.
Und wir kontrollieren, was Sie haben.
Man kann es behandeln, oder?
Ja, es könnte sein.
Ja, natürlich.
Es kann behandeln.
Muss ich denn jetzt heute hier im Krankenhaus bleiben
oder kann ich gleich wieder nach Hause?
Bis Ende dieser sogenannten Verfahren
durchgeführt würden,
sollen Sie bei uns beidun.
Okay.
Haben Sie einen Kollegen oder andere Fragen?
Ja, aber eine.
Alles schön.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ausland gewesen?
Ich meine, Tropischenländer, zum Beispiel in Afrika
oder South Asien?
Nein, ich war nur in Deutschland.
Also, haben Sie alle gegen etwas
oder Unverzüglichkeit?
Nicht bekannt.
Danke schön.
Haben Sie dort Brennen oder Sores aufstoßen?
Nein, gar nicht.
Brennungen haben Sie?
Nein.
Wie sieht Ihre Ürin aus?
Können Sie?
Der ist ein bisschen dunkler geworden in der letzten Zeit.
Aber jetzt auch nicht viel dunkler.
Das war ein ganz normales Zugang.
Der war eigentlich normal.
Das war nicht besonders gewesen.
Ja, der ist ein bisschen dunkler geworden.
Vielleicht habe ich wenig getrunken, ich weiß es nicht.
Aber da war es nicht besonders auffällig.
Herr Hund, gibt es bestimmte Auslöse für die Beschwerden?
Nein, das wundert mich auch.
Ich habe vielleicht eine Unbeträglichkeit.
Ob ich eventuell zufällig gegessen habe
oder ob ich meine Frau im Restaurant oder daher sein könnte.
Aber ich denke nicht.
Ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel die letzten zwei Tage gar nichts gegessen.
Trotzdem habe ich die Beschwerden.
Ich habe nur Wasser getrunken.
Am Anfang erst habe ich Essen.
Zum Beispiel nach dem Essen.
Oder wann sind die Schmerzen?
Wir waren ungefähr fünf Tage mit meiner Frau im Restaurant.
Wir haben Fisch gegessen.
Das hat dann am nächsten Abend angefangen.
Also nicht sofort.
Ich habe auch keinen Durchfall gehabt.
Nur die Schmerzen waren da.
Und dann anschließend kamen wir seit gestern,
habe ich starke Übungen mit der Bräche gehabt.
Und dann habe ich mir Sorgen gemacht.
Ich bin ins Krankenhaus gekommen.
Können wir als das gescheitert anfangen?
Ja, ich bin gespannt.
Guten Tag mein Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen.
Ihr seid dafür kurz.
Gerne.
Peter Hund ist 51 Jahre Patient.
Er kam heute wegen seit vier bis fünf Tagen Epigastrikoschmerzen zu uns.
Die Schmerzen sind dumpf und steckend.
Und dauerhaft, laut der Patientin,
liegen die Schmerzen bei 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Er hat 10 am stärksten.
Ja, 10 ist das, was ich gesagt habe.
Ja, er hat gesagt, das sind.
Momentan.
Also sehr stark Schmerzen hat er.
Momentan hat die Schmerzen nicht mehr so.
Ja, 4 bis 5.
Also doch, er hat Schmerzen.
Ja, er hat Schmerzen.
Zu Hause hat eine Profen-Novalgien eingenommen.
Deswegen ist er ein bisschen besser geworden.
Und viel Tropfen hat er eingenommen.
Ich habe nicht Fragen, aber bei Kopferlichen Unterzugs kann ich fragen.
Alles klar.
Er klagt über Nausea seit 5 Tagen.
Er ist seit gestern.
Und einmal hat er gebrochen.
Er sieht grün und gerbig aus.
Er hat keine Fieber und keine Schildfroß.
Er leidet in Appetenz und Müdigkeit.
Der letzte Stuhlgang war vor 3 Tagen.
Aber er hat nicht irgendwelche Veränderungen bemerkt.
Er hat in einer Woche 5 kg abgenommen.
Er hat abgenommen.
Er hat die Schmerzen in den Rücken ausgestrahlt.
Er hat bemerkt, dass der Patient gelbe,
er hat die Schmerzen in den Rücken ausgestrahlt.
Er hat ein Fisch gegessen.
Er hat seine Schmerzen plötzlich angefangen.
Er hat einen Tag später abgenommen.
Er leidet seit 10 Jahren.
Er nimmt 300 Tagel.
Er wurde in der Kindheit abhandaktumiert.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Er ist nicht Raucher und trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol.
Er ist verheiratet und hat keine Kinder.
Er ist Lehrer von Beruf.
Er ist ein Vater von 55 Jahren.
Er leidet Diabetes und Arterielechipartone.
Er ist einmal Operator?
Er ist abhandaktumiert.
Er hat vorhin schon 5 Tage angefangen.
Er hat gesagt, er würde in einer Woche abkommen.
Er hat keine Veränderung bemerkt.
Hat er die Schmerzen noch Gürtelform für mich?
Er hat gesagt, die Schmerzen streiten im Rücken aus.
Er hat gesagt, er würde in einem Rücken abkommen.
Ja, was sind hier die wichtigsten Eckpunkte oder Daten, die wir haben?
Welche Stichwörter sind die wichtigsten?
Seine Vater hat gleiche alte Karcinom hat.
Ja, das ist wichtig.
Aber die Bäsentomatik ist nicht ähnlich.
In einer Woche plus 5 kg abgenommen ist nicht, ich dachte nicht, Bäsentomatik.
Und er hat keine Fieber und Stufrost.
Die andere Seite hat er Icterus.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Es könnte sein eine Hepatitis oder eine Verstoffung in Gallenwege.
Ich gehe eine Kolelitiasis aus.
Und als die Paranialdiagnose kommt auch Hepatitis und Pancreatitis in Betracht.
Kann er auch ein Pankers Karcinom haben?
Ja, es könnte sein, aber die Bäsentomatik ist nicht so schnell.
Muss man unbedingt diese Art haben beim Karcinom? Muss das sein?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Hier ist wichtig, dass der Patient Oberbauchschmerzen hat.
Dass er Appetitlos ist.
Dass er ein Icterus hat.
Man muss immer auch an einen Karcinom denken.
Auch mit der familiären Vorgeschichte.
Aber das können wir jetzt noch nicht sagen.
Ist der Patient müde?
Ja, er leidet Partie.
Das ist auch ein Zeichen.
Das könnte ein böse Krankung sein.
Eine Neoplasie sein.
Was machen wir jetzt mit den Patienten?
Was für Untersuchungen machen Sie bei den Patienten?
Erstmal werde ich körperliche Untersuchungen danach Blut abnehmen.
Ich kontrolliere Blutbild- und Lebewerte, Nehrenwerte,
CRP, BSG, Entzündungparameter.
Was ist ganz wichtig, was Sie hier machen müssen?
Welche Laborparameter?
Leberwerte, Leberwerte, Leipase.
Ja, natürlich.
An Ihrer Stelle würde ich auch Tumormarke abnehmen.
An Ihrer Stelle.
Wenn Sie Blut abnehmen, kann man das mitbestimmen.
Wissen Sie, welche Tumormarke man hier abnimmt?
Momentan erinnere ich nicht.
Das ist CR199 und CEA kann man abnehmen.
Danke.
Gut, das hört sich gut an.
Was machen Sie als Erstes zu einer Diagnostik nach der Laborabnahme?
Eine Bildgebung.
Welche Bildgebung machen Sie?
Sonografie.
Genau.
Danach gegenwärts City-Computer-Tomografie.
Gut, ja.
Auch eine Ösephauge Gastrodionaskopie und Kolonaskopie.
Um auszuschließen, eine Magentrak-Karsinom.
Ja, wichtig ist hier die Magenspiegelung.
Mit der Magenspiegelung, je nach Labor befunden,
befunden eine Endosonografie.
Wissen Sie, was eine Endosonografie ist?
Ich habe gehört.
Das ist eine Magenspiegelung?
Ja.
Mit einem Ultraschall.
Ja, ich weiß.
Dann kann man das Panklers direkt vor Ort sehen.
Ob es Zysten gibt oder Neoplasien gibt.
Ob es Verengungen gibt.
Das kann man sehr gut sehen.
Man kann aber auch im Verlauf MR, CP, ER, CP machen.
Das kommt dann je nach Befund, was wir haben.
Was glauben Sie denn?
Es könnte ein Schulle-Zystole-Tier sein.
Glauben Sie, dass es sein kann?
Oder ein Schulle-Zystole-Tier?
Bei der Patient hat er keinen Fieber.
Er hat keine Schüttelfrost.
Keine richtige Entzündung.
Keine richtige Entzündung, Parameter.
Die haben recht, wie es könnte sein, eine Karcinone.
Könnte sein.
Warum könnte es das sein?
An einem Nestig.
Der Vater hat ähnliche Jahre eine Karcinone.
Er leidet an Fatigue.
Ich habe ja am Anfang gefragt,
was sind die Kernpunkte, die Kernhossagen?
Er hat Gewichtsverlust.
Er hat ein Iterus.
Er hat Appetitlosigkeit.
Er hat Müdigkeit.
Dieser Iterus hat natürlich Oberbaubeschwerden.
Normalerweise haben Sie, wenn Sie jemanden haben,
der eine Schulle-Zystole-Tier ist,
eine Schulle-Docherle-Tier ist,
keinen Gewichtsverlust.
Die Leute kommen auch viel schneller zum Harz,
weil die Schmerzen eigentlich plötzlich beginnen.
Aber bei diesen Patienten war das so langsam, schleichend.
In den 25 Tagen ist immer mehr geworden.
Ich habe eine Frage, Murat.
Warum?
Man muss hier immer an einen Karcinon denken,
weil die Symptome nicht plötzlich aufgetreten sind,
sondern nacheinander.
Es kann hier Panklers Kopfkarcinon sein,
weil der Iterus auch später aufgetreten ist.
Er hat die Beschwerden nicht schon seit 4 bis 5 Tagen,
die Beschwerden sind drückendes, stechendes Gefühl.
Anschließend hat er auch ein Iterus bemerkt,
der aber noch nicht so ausgeprägt ist.
Er hat nicht den ganzen Körper, der ist nicht ganz Geld,
aber die Augen sind ein bisschen Geld geworden.
Dann kann es schon sein, dass dieses Karcinon
ein Panklers Kopf auf den Duktus drückt.
Langsam, aber sicher wird es zugehen.
Insbesondere der Gewichtsverlust und die Müdigkeit
sind Anzeichen für eine maligere Erkrankung in diesem Fall.
Bei Panklers Kopfkarcinon sehr oft in dieser Konstellation.
Wenn sie jetzt eine Schule doch und natürlich kann es auch
ein Deilengangskarcinon sein, wissen wir nicht.
Kann auch sein.
Das müssen wir in der Bildgebung sehen.
Aber die Verdachtdiagnose bei sehr schnellem Gewichtsverlust
sollte immer in diesem Fall auch Panklers Kopfkarcinon sein.
Haben wir noch einen anderen?
Oder habe ich etwas vergessen?
Habe ich etwas falsch gesagt?
Vielen Dank für ihn, es ist sehr hilfreich.
Vielen Dank.
Was sehen wir beim Ultraschall?
Beim Ultraschall.
Können Sie, wenn Sie ein guter Erfahrung mit Ultraschall haben,
können Sie auch schon das Panklers Kopfkarcinon sehen.
Sie können sehen, dass eventuell der Duktus Pankraticus
oder der Duktus Scholedorhus eingeengt ist
durch das Panklers Kopfkarcinon.
Sie können die Verkalkungen sehen.
Sie können aber auch eine Raumforderung
ganz gut sehen normalerweise.
Aber das ist natürlich beim Panklers immer etwas schwierig.
Wenn es Staatenmethyrysmus gibt oder der Patient Alipöse ist,
dann ist das oft schwierig zu sehen.
Was Sie aber gut sehen können, ist zum Beispiel,
ob es eine intrapasische Scholestase gibt.
Das können Sie gut sehen, ob die geilen Wege in den Leber
erweitert sind.
Ob es ein doppeltindes Phänomen gibt
oder ob der Patient Geilensteine hat
oder ob die Geilenblase verdickt ist,
ob es eine Geilenblase in Zündung gibt.
Das kann auch sein, aber hier deutet alles eher auf
eine Panklers Kopfkarcinone oder eine Panklers Karcinone
bei einer maligen Erkrankung.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Können Sie unter sheet well informativerhaft
die Schmerzen-Eltlerin?
Wellenförmig bedeutet also kolikartig.
Zum Beispiel haben Sie das,
wenn Sie einen Nierenstein haben.
Die Patienten sind schmerzfrei
und plötzlich kommt es wieder.
Und dann ist es schmerzfrei und plötzlich wieder.
Es hängt damit zu tun, durch die Peristaltik
bis aneleiters.
Das ist auch der Fall,
dass die Patienten in der Zündung genauso.
Dauerhafter Schmerz hat dieser Patient,
er hat ja aktuell Schmerzen von 4 bis 5.
Aber drückende Schmerzen hat er
und manchmal kommen die Schmerzen so stark,
dass es wie ein Messer ist
und ja auf einer Skala von 9 ist.
Es ist also nicht regelmäßig.
Es gibt immer Wellenförmig.
Sie können sagen,
ich habe keine Schmerzen,
aber in 3 Minuten habe ich wieder Schmerzen.
Sie können sich vorher sehen.
Bei plötzlichen Schmerzen, dauerhaft Schmerzen,
können Sie diesen Schmerz, der unerwartet kommt,
nicht vorher sehen.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Jetzt sie wie die Schmerzen
sind eigentlich auch immer wieder
auftretende Schmerzen.
Immer wieder haben sie diese Beschwerden.
Das bedeutet aber,
dass sie wahrscheinlich
ab und zu keine Schmerzen haben,
sondern dass sie immer wieder auftauchen.
Aber das kann man nicht gleichsetzen
und die Lierende
gleich Wellenförmig.
Dann gibt es eine besondere Name
für die Schmerzen,
wenn sie nachgelassen ist.
Das ist Rizidivierend.
Rizidivierende Schmerzen,
die sie aber nicht in einem Zeitabstand
abmessen können.
Man kann diese schmerzenden Schmerzen
sehr gut im Rahmen eines Hanleitersteins
sehen.
Oder zum Beispiel kann man so ein bisschen
vergleichen mit Wellen, bei der Geburt der Frau.
Dann können Sie sehen, okay,
ich habe jetzt keine Beschwerden und dann kommen die Wellen
wieder alle zwei Minuten, ungefähr so.
Deswegen haben zum Beispiel Nieren-Kolikpatienten,
die müssen sich immer bewegen, sind sehr unruhig.
Weil Sie wissen, gleich kommt der Schmerz wieder
und gleich ist es wieder soweit.
Da können Sie den Zeitabstand ganz gut
dokumentieren.
Bei Rizidivierenden Schmerzen, dann würde ich ja so beschreiben,
Sie haben die Schmerzen, dann sind die lange Zeit nicht da
und plötzlich sind sie wieder da.
Lange Zeit nicht da, vielleicht über mehrere Minuten,
dann sind die Schmerzattacke da.
Aber in diesem Fall haben wir einen Dauerschmerz.
Dauererschmerz, also muss auch nicht sein,
beim Pankreiskarzinom, das ist jetzt in diesem Fall so.
Manchmal haben die gar keine Schmerzen.
Manchmal sind die schmerzlose Ektros
immer ein Zeichen für Pankreis-Kopfkarzinom.
In diesem Fall hatte er Schmerzen gehabt,
aber er muss auch keine Schmerzen haben.
Wenn er keine Schmerzen hat und Geld wird,
ein Ektros bekommt, muss man immer an den Pankreiskarzinom denken.
Ich würde noch eine Frage.
Nicht Kurvaliers,
Mörfi Zeichen, bitte Sie eklären.
Können Sie mir eklären?
Mörfi Zeichen, die Schmerzen,
die Sie haben, die Sie haben,
zum Beispiel auch unter dem Rippenbogen.
Ja, Kurvaliers Zeichen, das muss ich nochmal
selber nachlesen, Moment.
Kurvaliers Zeichen, ich weiß,
Prelle ausgefüllte Schmerzlose,
Schmerzlose,
Aber Mörfi Zeichen,
Ich habe gelesen,
Aber Mörfi Zeichen unter dem Rippenbogen
im Prinzip, reindrücken,
einatmen lassen, dann haben Sie
die Schmerzen nicht mehr hinspiratschant.
Inspiration, Inspiration.
Okay, danke schön.
Noch eine Frage?
Ein bisschen schwieriger Fall gewesen, heute glaube ich.
Nein, nicht schwieriger.
Gut, sehr gut.